we had our own little notebook that was
actually austin's idea which was a
really awesome idea
and we would write each other things
that i won't talk about and then leave
it for each other
in dressing rooms so we got to know each
other that way
dear dash i can say that now
because i finally know your name well i
just have to commend both of you because
lily and dash barely had any scenes
together
and yet your chemistry was just so
electric
how did you guys bond off screen in
order to find that on-screen connection
we went to a dive bar we went to a sushi
restaurant
austin austin was in from la and so
we truly did like it would be i don't
know every what once every two weeks or
something we would go out and we'd talk
about
what are you filming what am i feeling
and we got to know each other as people
we had our own little notebook that was
actually austin's idea which was a
really awesome idea and we
would write each other things that i
won't talk about
and then leave it for each other in
dressing rooms
so we got to know each other that way
that's amazing did you leave each other
any little dares as well
it was kind of more about like um trying
to bond with each other kind of in a
similar way that they
were doing in the show so i think that
was like the motivation there
i think austin you're supposed to burn
it did you i burned it yeah
okay cool did you really yeah
you need to frame that no no no no
no no no no we could take the bridge and
hit that ocean parkway
lily midori i don't know about you but
my parents would have killed me if i had
ditched them in a cab on route to the
airport but it was so nice to see that
we did get our little happy ending
how do you guys think that they spent
new year's day together yeah like i
don't know what if they
like both stay in there the whole night
if you think or did they leave and go
home maybe they got breakfast i i don't
know
i'd like to think that after a certain
point of knowing we were gonna get in
trouble and grounded that we were just
like okay whatever so we stayed there
all night and then yeah i think we
probably went to like a diner and got
breakfast
and then parted and then got grounded
for the rest of the day and probably
couldn't leave home
totally worth it oh that sounds good i
got you a notebook
you can mail it from puerto rico i love
the fact that both langston and boomer
got their rom-com happy ending at the
end
of season one but i was dying to know
how they spent their new year's day
i feel like he would be surrounded by
everyone like he
boomer would just make sure there's
either a party happening or he's going
to a party i think he he's a party guy
he has libra energy
i'm gonna say that oh i like that i
think langston was probably just in his
favorite spot which was
at his home on his roof with benny with
with two blankets
at least two blankets it's not about the
first kiss
it's about the first one that matters
fingers crossed though for season two
i feel like fans are immediately going
to want to know if there could be a
second season
there are multiple books what do you
guys think and would it only be
centered around the holidays i don't
know you know i think
we have to wait for it to come out
before netflix decides if they want to
do that or not i mean yeah i can only
assume that i think it would have to do
with the second book
it did i would like to see everything
that rachel and david wrote in
the second book i would like to stay
true to their vision
i feel like they've made several books
for this exact thing so
why can't the show continue as we as
actors continue showing
the fans what they want to see from the
characters we're portraying a whole
different world people are expecting
these characters to come to life
there's some some things coming and
they're working on it i love it
midori any thoughts on season two
anything you'd like to um yeah i mean i
hear where you're going with this
question
of course it's always in the back of our
minds but i would say especially in
times like these
we're just so grateful that we have this
show done
and shot and that we get to show it to
you and we're so proud of our season
and i think that we're going to leave it
there and and
see how see how it goes
what was that sometimes words aren't
enough
[Music]